ja alter halt dein maul wahrscheinlich
wird er die essenslieferung hin und
tickt jan in die wohnung rein oder herz
bekommen soll wann wie die leute es ist
wieder an der zeit dass wir mal
miteinander ein ernstes wörtchen über
die pranke aussehen wenn wir mal ehrlich
miteinander sind leute und so darüber
nachdenken welche youtuber so auf
youtube in deutschland am meisten dafür
bekannt sind halt sachen zu faken und
irgendwie ihre zuschauer zu verarschen
dann sind es ja eigentlich die frank
bröckling und manche würden auch noch
boni träsch sagen und die sache ist
rebecca will kriegt immer so eine
richtige breitseite wisst ihr weil die
sich auch irgendwie ungeschickter dabei
angestellten zu verstetigen diesmal aber
die bank braucht sind eigentlich noch
dreister als rebecca wing und ich
persönlich finde dass wir die prank broß
zuseher und zu schnell vermarkten lassen
wisst ihr was ich meine leute ich dabei
den pressen wir auf so sind wir nur die
prank bronze wir sind ja nicht anders
aber aber ich wollte mit diesem video
sagen heute ich glaube wir sollten dem
frank rost nicht so schnellen pass geben
natürlich gar nicht angehoben werden
soll das video fünf mal daran aber im
selben lieferservice bestellen kann man
auf eskaliert ganz kurz vorne weg dazu
das video ist relativ offensichtlich und
dreist von lx wie geklaut das schon mal
das erste bis 2 des alex selbst hatte
auch schon reaktion gemacht die habe ich
euch als ersten link in der beschreibung
von links die auch gerne ab und das
dritte ist einfach die art und weise wie
dieses video gefällt ist einfach so
krass dreist und lächerlich dass ich das
euch auf jeden fall zeigen wollte
versuchen und dementsprechend
provozieren nicht mehr kommen oder ok
also ist das prinzip von diesen wir sie
wollen steht auf dem titel fünfmal
hintereinander beim selben lieferservice
bestellen und dann irgendwie den
lieferanten dazu provozieren dass er
irgendwie eine extreme reaktion zeigt
muss ich noch mal explizit sagen leute
das video ist natürlich von vorne bis
hinten einfach dreist gefaked und zwar
hat sich einer von den beiden einfach
als lieferant verkleidet und die
reaktion von dem lieferanten
geschauspielert nicht unbedingt die
klügste entscheidung aber er werde
gleich verstehen was ich meine leute
schauen wir weiter
aber wie oft das geld zum kleines
experiment wir tun ja eigentlich regulär
bezahlen und wurden die grenzen haben
und das ist wird es heute und ja wir
bestellen online über eine ssl um leute
man schaut sich jetzt so diese
screenshot von denen an wohl wissend
dass einfach der rechte von den beiden
ich weiß ich weiß wirklich nicht fest
ist also ich verwechsle den namen immer
wieder der rechte von den beiden
verkleidet sie gleich als lieferant und
schauspieler die ganze sache und damit
dass man wenn man das weiß und den so
zuhört wie sie darüber reden dass jetzt
ein experiment machen und gucken wie der
liefer boote reagiert wenn sie korrekt
und dann wären wir kriegen die
vielleicht auf etwas trinke genau wenn
nicht dann ist er ganz gern denke sie
wahrscheinlich krieg die lieferanten
trinke bruder leon titel gebührt
sicherlich selbst ein trickbetrüger also
ich glaube ganz ehrlich dass niemand
daran gedacht hat dass der kanal name
prangt groß weil sie diese bedeutung
annehmen würde also ich meine der man
irgendwann gemeint dass sie keine franks
machen wollen auf ihrem kanal de facto
machen sie aber bremst und zwar dem
projekt das sie einfach sei ticks videos
immer wieder ihre eigenen
zuschauerschaft verarschen aber nach
strich und faden und ja es ist einfach
so ein trauerspiel leute weil ihre
zuschauer sind so jung dieses video hat
91.000 likes immer noch obwohl es
wirklich einfach dreist dreist gefegt
ist und ich weiß sollte also ich bin
auch kein heiliger auf youtube aber das
hat mich einfach so die richter
löw sagen ein bisschen provokant zu
wirken bestellen ok also bestellen sie
eine pizza okay das gibt mir mal vor zu
dem zeitpunkt wo die erste lieferung
ankommt ok also dass schon die erste
sache also sie haben hier einfach mitten
ins treppenhaus auf dem boden eine
kamera gestellt aber auf jeden fall also
man erkennt da jetzt nichts aus um auf
dieser kamera also man darf davon
ausgehen dass die kamera einfach mitten
auf dem leeren boden im treppenhaus
steht ok ok andererseits warum rede ich
überhaupt darüber wir wissen schon das
ist einer von den beiden ist allen
lieferanten spiel so ok dann stoppen wir
mal hier die ja also wir sehen einen
lieferanten der ja ich sag mal etwas
ungewöhnliche proportionen hat so die
beine scheinen recht trainiert zu sein
die arme scheinen auch recht trainiert
zu sein die brust ist wahrscheinlich
auch relativ muskulös und rausgestreckt
aber der bauch passt irgendwie nicht so
zum restlichen körper
ob man sich da vielleicht irgendwas noch
das hemd gestopft hat um auszusehen wie
ein etwas beleibter die verbote die
antwort ist ja wir springen wir also
minute 842 sieht man relativ gut dass
sie irgendwie ein dunkelblaues kisten
und das hemd gestopft haben man sieht ja
auch mit dem die verboten von hinten
also diese person ist nicht okay ist nur
sehr trainierte person und dieser bauch
sind einfach kissen die sich darunter
gestopft aber egal das ist für ein
scheiß
ok also ersten lieferung relativ
unproblematisch effekt hat eine sache
eine müssen antiken zurückspulen
passend natürlich leute ist einer von
den beiden immer hinter der kamera
die frage ist warum ist einer von den
beiden immer hinter der kamera die haben
die kamera einfach auf einem stativ
gestellt also niemand muss die kamera
halten oder irgendwas trotzdem
vereinbaren sie dass einer von den
beiden zu tun ist und der andere hinter
der kamera bleibt komplett unter sind
liegt natürlich daran dass der der
hinter der kamera ist den lieferanten
spielt wird hierbei minute 155 sieht man
nämlich unten links im bild einfach dass
wein von dem stativ auf dem die kamera
steht ja warum zur hölle muss hat einen
hinter die kamera
kleine besser ich springe mal zur
zweiten bestellung und schauen uns da
die reaktion des leaf verboten an
leute es einfach so krass wie man sieht
dass da irgendwas unter den bauch
gestoppt wurde der körper passt einfach
vorne und hinten nicht zusammen also
echt viel dreister kann man nicht einmal
so was dieses grinsen was sie die ganze
drauf und leute wisst ihr was er mit
sicherheit mit schwingt da schwingt mit
sicherheit zu dieser bremseffekt mit
dass sie sich einfach konstant in ihre
videos darüber lustig machen dass ihre
eigene zuschauerschaft so dumm ist diese
gefakten videos zu gucken und auch noch
zu feiern
safe leute selbst alle andere youtuber
sind 200.000 auf fast immer eine
community zeit nicht voll wie cool ist
das denn so wird 2000 aufrufen wie dumm
sind die auf unser video zu klicken
dritte bestellungen okay dritter
bestellung jetzt leute
also ohne günstiger lieferant ist erst
zum dritten mal da okay und er hat auch
jedes mal trinkgeld bekommen
warum sollte sich ein lieferant darüber
abfangen so lange wir nicht 30 mal am
selben tag in den verwandten ins selbe
haus schick warum sollte sich darüber ab
wer bekommt jedes mal sein trinkgeld ob
jetzt hier hin fährt oder irgendeine
andere bude irgendwo in der stadt macht
auch ein unterschied also ich meine
leute wir wissen längst dass es einer
von den beiden ist der sich der einfach
nur in kisten unter dem bauch gestopft
hat ja aber selbst wenn wir das mal
ausblenden was zu der begründung ist
dass mit tank browser macht auch keinen
unterschied ob die jetzt zu irgendwo
anderen haus fährst oder zu deren haus
naja wahrscheinlich bis zu übergewichtig
oder springreiter leute führte
bestellungen mal gucken was hier
passiert
ja alter halt dein maul wahrscheinlich
dürfte die ersten lieferungen hin und
kickte dann in die wohnung rein oder der
sorry es tut mir wirklich leid für alle
zehnjährigen in deutschland die das
glauben vor allem warum sowas die
begründung okay ist zum vierten mal in
diesem haus so es bisschen ungewöhnlich
aber er kriegt genauso trinkgeld für
jede fahrt trinke haben sie gesagt und
ob 1 dahin fällt oder irgendwo anders
ist doch scheißegal
klar kommt dass es für ein bisschen
verarscht vor aber wahrscheinlich kickte
deswegen so das essen in die wohnung
rein der lacht sich auf einen ab
natürlich dass die stadt ihre ich meine
weil jeder andere der in der situation
wäre würde sich so richtig gestresst
fühlen ich so eine fremde person ist
aggressiv gegenüber ein bisschen stress
situationen die abdeckkappe nach ihm
geschlagen und er lacht sich natürlich
einen abweist sein eigener bruder auf
der anderen seite der tür ist und er
sich denkt egal wie geisteskranken sind
youtube zuschauer eigentlich aber naja
ok hat das gehört wollte er sagte am
liebsten am liebsten würde ich mit dir
zusammen an die tür gehen dann macht
doch einfach liga also entweder du bist
der fucking die verbote oder du kannst
einfach machen beim auto stieß hinter
der kamera okay die kamera steht einen
meter von der tür entfernt wie schwer
kann es sein hinter der kamera heraus
einen schritt zu machen und zu tür zu
gehen
liebend gern würde ich mal mit dir
zusammen der tür steht
also auch komplett dummen gelegt jetzt
der lieferbar tisch aber die pizzen
dahin
warum
[Musik]
hey leute ohne mist jetzt gebt euch das
war also ganz kurz mal eine ernste
message an alle youtube zuschauer gerade
an die jungen zuschauer okay
schaut euch diese szene in diesem post
video erläutert diese szene ist so
schlecht gefällt dass der typ selbst
lachen muss während er sie fragte wie
kann es sein dass dieses video trotzdem
90.000 likes hat also wieder größer so
dumm kann die menschheit eigentlich
nicht sein außerdem weiß ich noch gar
nicht angesprochen habe ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass das hat alex wir
auch gesagt in einem video wie gesagt
erst mal in der beschreibung texas ab
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass fünf mal
derselbe typ kommt ist so gering ich
habe selbst mal meinem studium bei einer
pizzeria gejobbt und da waren immer
mehrere fahrer zeitgleich unterwegs und
es hat immer derjenige der gerade
reingekommen ist die fahrt bekommen die
gerade gemacht werden sollte werde jetzt
natürlich nicht fünf meinte der
gleichgekommen wäre die reaktion
bestimmt nicht so krass gewesen aber gut
ist auf dem posten als info ist schauen
wir einfach scheißegal ist ob dinge
tatsächlich passiert sind oder ob sie
nur gefällt wurden denn den achtjährigen
einzellern die dieses video schauen
fällt im zweifelsfall nicht auf leute
was haltet ihr davon habt ihr dieses
video schon gesehen was war ihre erste
reaktion als gesehen habt und was ist
euer vorschlag wie sollte man mit dem
frank boss auf youtube weiter umgehen
das geld in die kommentare an jackie
darüber im vorstand das video ab und
hier oben könnt ihr einen kanal gefallen
hat das was mir auch das soll falls
bilanz habe das sind heute 40 grad in
köln
ja ich größere augen macht gut bis zum
nächsten mal